right if everybody's attention please I
think I forgot that this is the
Declaration of result of poll for the
election of a member of parliament for
Nuneaton on Thursday the 7th of May 2015
iron francs being the acting returning
officer for the needs Nuneaton
constituency declared that the total
number of votes given to each candidate
was as follows Victoria Nina Jane Fowler
Labour Party candidate 15000 945
Cristina Rita
Jeb Limerick Liberal Democrats 816
Marcus Charles Jones the Conservative
Party candidate 20,000
827 Keith and Adi Antony Khan darker
green party 1281 Stephen James Paxton
English Democrats putting England first
104 Paul Edward Reilly trade unionist
and socialist coalition 194 and and
Alwyn joy Wayne UK Independence Party
you get six thousand five hundred and
eighty-two therefore I give public
notice but Marcus Charles Jones is duly
elected as the Member of Parliament for
the neaten constituency
the total number of votes cast across
Nuneaton at the UK parliamentary
election on the 7th of May 2015 was
forty five thousand seven hundred and
forty nine and the total number of
ballot papers rejected was seventy-five
and at this stage I'll hand over to the
candidates starting with Marcus Jones
Wow he despite the result it's always a
hard fight in the neaten and that's
exactly what we had we had a hard fight
and I'd like to thank the hundreds of
conservative activists we had on the
ground supporting me in this campaign
getting me over the line tonight thank
you guys
but also like to thank my campaign
manager Beth Ann who's been absolutely
fantastic
and I'd like to give a big big thank you
to Susanne my wife and and the rest of
my family who have been magnificent
supporters over the last five years and
I couldn't have done it without you guys
I'd also like to thank all those people
here tonight in the counting agents I'd
like to thank all of the people who've
worked on the election from Anita bed
Earth Borough Council thank yous and
extremely efficiently run election and
is extremely efficiently in well-run
count and I thank you for that I'd also
like to thank all of the other
candidates who have played a very
important role in tonight's election and
played an important role in making the
election in a hard fight and above all
though at the ball of that I would
really like to thank the people of Ninh
Eaton our Lee and Hartzell for putting
their faith in me five years ago I said
to the people of nanine Arlene Hartzell
that regardless of the way they voted I
would represent them to the best of my
ability I think tonight the people of
maneet and Arlene Hartzell they voted
for me on that record of working hard
for them both in the constituency and
both in Parliament five years ago I came
into office as a Member of Parliament
for this constituency and the country
had been through one of the worst
recessions in living memory the country
economically was in a complete mess
after five years the conservative-led
government has started to turn that mess
around and we are now on the right path
and I'm absolutely convinced that my
record and the record of the
conservative leg coalition is absolutely
why I'm here with an increased majority
tonight and tonight this is one of the
first ultra marginal constituencies to
declare
and tonight we've got the glare of the
national media here neaten tonight is on
the map nan Eaton tonight as spoken I
think for Britain I'm absolutely sure
that thanks for your support